Chúc khi báo chi xuất hiện, công hơi ngâm mắt tình tức bằng cách nào.
Chỉnh khi mạnh chúng ta từng thấy, người xưa chuyến tinh cho nhau bằng sọng nói bức trân và kế ước.
Tưởng những người lính trở về sông trận chiến đến các thương ra khuy thuộc và kể ước hành.
Tình tức là chuyến qua lời kể và chiến nhớ.
Họ chính là những phòng viên đầu tiên, không dễ mốt, không lịch gồm, nhưng mang theo cả thế giới trên vài.
Tại truà ho thời của đại người là má đe sáng tạo ra a tài giù nào, bản thí chép các sự kiện công cộng, được dân ở nơi đông nơi, báo tình xin tự kết hôn và tình đồ chứ chính,
đây được xem là tình thân đầu tiên của báo chi viết.
Tuy nhiên phải đến nămu yên bốn trang bốn nơi khi cho hành ás của tình báo phát mình giá mại in,
năng xuất gấp hơn chết tay cả đi lần, tí lịch sự báo chi mới thực sự bức sản trạm mới,
nhờ máy in tình thức có thể được in hành loạt, nhé hơn, giải hơn, và phủ viên hơn.
Đây là tờ báo íên đầu tiên của nhân loại, xa đời tại đất của nămu yên sống trang lại chính.
Sau đó, báo chi viên trong lần dọng khắp cho ông, báo vừa đại dương tới cho Mỹ.
Tại bóc tên nămu yên sống trang chính người Pháp Lích Aug. 10, tờ báo đầu tiên của Mỹ trào đời.
Chỉ đề bị cấm, sông một số ngày phát thành vì thiếu sự kiểm so yet.
Quên tự giò báo chi chỉ được chính thức công nhận nămu yên bài trăm chỉ mốt trong tù chính ngàn thức nhất của nhân Pháp Lích.
Nhưng mại đến những nămu yên tâm trang báo người, báo chi mới trở thành phương tiện đại chúng thật sự,
nhiều tờ tất sang, tờ báo đầu tiên được bán với giá chỉ một số,
đến tất ngon không còn là đặc quyền của Mỹ sau.
Như kinh mạng công nghiệp, ngành in đã tất tờ bầu kỳ lục tới Mỹ nghiên tờ mối sở.
Năm 1 nghiên tâm trăm năm gây, Mỹ có khoảng 2 nghiên năm trong tờ báo, đến năm nghiên tâm trăm chỉ người có số ai vượt người một nghiên,
một số tờ phát thành hôm một trự bản.
Cùng thời gian này, khi mình hoạt tiêu đề biểu ngữ và chuyện tranh là nượt ra đời khi báo ín ngày cảnh thêm của nốt.
Nhưng báo ín cũng không ai sử dụng thể đột tôn.
Sử dụng ra đời của video, chuyện hình và sông này là internet đã thay đổi thoại quan tích nhận thông tin.
Dù vậy, báo chỉ vẫn thích nghi, các tờ báo lớn vẫn tổn tại.
Vừa dứt bản đến vừa phát triển lình cảnh số.
Báo chỉ hôm nay không còn dưới hạn trong tay cái nhỏ xuất bản.
Ai cũng có thể làm báo, xuất bản tinh tất, chỉ bằng vài của nấp trụt.
Nhưng dù ở hình thức ngào, bản trích của báo chỉ vẫn không thể đổi.
Y nghĩ lại hiện thật, sau sáng sự thật và kể lại những khu truyện mang sức ngạng của thời đại.